There are a lot of ways we can break this
movie down, so let’s start with the opening
credits.
They are a montage of mysterious, grungy images
and subliminal messages.
Many of these show preparations made by the
serial killer, John Doe, such as him throwing
himself into books about the Seven Deadly
Sins, the Christian teachings upon which his
crimes are based.
Detectives Somerset and Mills eventually use
his library records to track him down.
There are also images of razor blades and
John cutting the skin off of his fingers, which
turns out to be part of the reason that law
enforcement is unable to find any fingerprints
at any of his crime scenes or even while searching
his apartment.
“We haven’t found a fingerprint yet.
Not a single one.”
“You’re right.
I don’t believe you.
Keep looking.”
The title sequence also includes his darkroom
for developing photos and his writing of personal
manifestos, both part of his incredible collection
of journals and photographic documentation
of his work, which he expects to be remembered
and studied for years to come.
“And what I’ve done is going to be puzzled
over, and studied, and followed...
...forever.”
I think the same could be said of David Fincher’s
movie, but that’s beside the point.
A behind-the-scenes documentary shows how
the art department created hand sewn notebooks,
and they speak of wanting to nail the ‘personality’
of Doe’s penmanship.
“They wanted this kind of  ‘obsessive’ quality
to the handwriting.”
And we see a similar style of writing overlaid
on top of the title sequence.
Some of these messages only appear for as
short as 1/24th of a second, but once deciphered,
we can use them to better understand some
of the hidden details in this film, so stick
around to the end of this video, because I’ll
be unpacking EVERYTHING.
This video is sponsored by Raycon.
Welcome to Things You Missed, in today’s
episode I’ll be going over 7 things you
might have missed in David Fincher’s sophomore
film:
Se-seven-en.
Now you may be angrily typing right now: “Why
aren’t you starting with his first film:
Alien cubed?”
Well, I figure I’m gonna do the Alien franchise
at some point, and when I do, I’m gonna
do them all together.
So before I get to that, there is no shortage
of excellent horror-thriller types in Fincher’s
catalogue, and Se7en is an ideal place to
start.
“You know this isn’t gonna have a happy
ending.”
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
Some of the messages that briefly flash on
screen during the title sequence look to be
alphanumeric codes.
For example, D-35 comes up several times and
there’s also a brief D-36.
Another one that comes up a couple times is
C-24.
But what do these strange codes actually mean?
While there are a number of possibilities,
I like to look at the psychological battle
between the detectives and the killer they
are trying to catch like a game of chess.
In chess, there are a number of strategies
called gambits.
Simply put, a gambit is a calculated risk
taken with the hope that it will give the
player the upper hand.
So I might allow my opponent to take one of
my pieces in order to ultimately get the positioning
I want, and get a check-mate.
"If I accept this invitation I'll be giving into his intent.
I can't allow this.
This humiliation!
*gasps*
One famous instance of this is the Queen’s
Gambit Declined, which is known in the chess
community as variation D-35.
There’s also a similar variation known as
D-36.
C-24 is another gambit, known as the Bishop’s
Opening.
If you think about it, John Doe’s strategy
to get what he wants from Mills is basically
a gambit.
He willingly gives himself up to the police
in order to set things in motion.
This forces the detectives into the position
he wants them in, because they have to take
him outside of the city limits to find the
two bodies that he supposedly hid out there.
And ultimately, it leads to a check-mate against
Detective Mills, who can’t restrain himself
after finding what John Doe did to his wife.
After killing her he delivers her head to
the detectives inside of a box, and by doing
so, he completes his mission.
She would be the sixth victim, Envy -- and
Mills would take his revenge, making John
Doe the seventh victim: Wrath.
John Doe set up the pieces perfectly, and
Mills found himself to be nothing more than
a piece in his masterful game of chess.
“He’s playing games.”
“No ****.”
“It’s a part of the game.”
The experienced Detective Somerset is much
better at not falling for John Doe’s tricks
than Detective Mills, who lets his emotions
overtake him, causing him to make stupid moves.
Perhaps this is because Somerset has some
experience in the game of chess, while Mills
is more of a basketball guy.
Basketball is also a game that requires strategy,
spacing, and a good gameplan, but basketball
has a much higher pace of play due to it’s
24 second shot clock.
Unlike chess, a lot of moves need to be made
on the fly, which explains why Mills’ actions
on the spot can get him into a lot of trouble,
leaving him as a vulnerable target for a thoughtful,
calculating villain such as John Doe.
Think of Mills like the JR Smith of this movie.
"Rebound goes to the Cavs, JR Smith brings it back out!
Throws it to Hill *buzzer*
"It is one of the most brain dead, idiotic things that I've ever witnessed."
There are many scenes that highlight how Mills’s
impulsiveness contrasts to Somerset’s guile.
Like how Somerset does his studying with long
nights at the library, while Mills skims the
Cliff’s Notes.
How Somerset has carefully thought about leaving
his city for 34 years while Mills jumps to
rent an apartment after five minute tours
with a slimy realtor.
“The soothing, relaxing, vibrating home.”
*laughter*
How Mills recklessly runs into danger after
a suspect while Somerset asks around for a
back exit.
And ultimately, how Somerset is content with
capturing John Doe, and doesn’t want to
play into his hands any further, while Mills
can’t just let him sit around in prison,
and is more inclined to accept his offer and
go out to find the remaining two victims.
“Full confession.
I’m in.”
The differing approaches from the two detectives
are a result of their circumstances, which
are quite opposite of one another.
In both basketball and chess, opponents each
have their own side.
Your teammate should be headed in the same
direction that you are, but Mills is celebrating
his first seven days on the job, while Somerset
is counting down his last seven.
The movie shows us how their experience dictates
how they interact with the city.
One of their first scenes together has them
walking down the street together.
The experienced Somerset flows seamlessly
through the pedestrian traffic, while Mills
is bumping into people and going around people.
He has a lot to learn about his new environment.
“I worked homicide five years.”
“Not here.”
“I understand that.”
“Well over the next seven days detective,
you’ll do me the favor of remembering that.”
As they investigate the first crime scene,
the one that represents Gluttony, Somerset
is focused on the job, looking for clues,
but his partner is making small-talk, and
again, the way the scene is presented says
more than the screenplay itself.
The music almost overpowers the volume of
Mills’s frivolous comments, like he’s
trying to block out the distraction with his
focus.
We see Somerset do essentially the same thing
at home, using his metronome to help him sleep
while horrible things are happening just outside
his walls.
When I’m looking to drown out the noises
and distractions of the outside world, I turn
to my Raycon Everyday E25 Earbuds.
These earbuds are the best model yet.
I can’t tell you how freeing it is to just
link these up to my phone, and move around
the house all day, not having to worry about
wires getting in my way, or getting tangled,
or getting caught on something and yanking
them out of my ears.
You can just drown out the sound of sirens,
gunshots, or even your roommates!
And with six hours of playtime, more bass
and a compact noise isolating design, Raycons
are perfect for all your audio listening needs.
Click the link in the description, that’s
buy raycon dot com slash czsworld to get fifteen
percent off your order today!
Perhaps the biggest and most important difference
between Detective Somerset and Detective Mills
is highlighted in this bar scene, where Somerset
explains why he’s quitting and leaving the
city.
“I just don't think I can continue to live
in a place that embraces and nurtures apathy
as if it was virtue.”
He’s trying to warn the younger detective
that in this city, not caring is celebrated,
and he thinks that attitude is the reason
people in this community get involved with
drugs, crime, and abuse.
Love, on the other hand, takes effort and
work.
Somerset admits that he’s no better than
anyone else, that he’s part of the problem,
because he often takes the easy route by being
apathetic.
But while he claims to have this cynical view
of himself and his city, his actions suggest
otherwise.
Early on he suggests to be taken off the case
because he doesn’t want to end his career
on something that will just drag on and on,
but his supervisor, who he’s worked with
for years doesn’t buy his story.
“I don’t think you’re leaving.
You can’t leave all this.
You do this work.
You were made for it and I don’t think you
can deny that.
Maybe I'm wrong."
Somerset disagrees, however, in that same
scene, he tells off a maintenance man who
is scraping the detective’s name off of
his door.
“Excuse me.
Excuse me.
Could you not do that please?”
It’s almost like a subconscious part of
him doesn’t want his name removed from that
office, despite his insistence otherwise.
“I can’t get involved in this.”
But moments later, he walks past a banner.
“Do you know what you’ve been getting
into?
Are you positive?”
Maybe he does, maybe he doesn’t.
But he does get more and more involved as
the case goes on, and I think he is very much
aware of it.
At the beginning of the movie, he tells a
cab driver that he’s on his way out...
“Where you headed?”
“Far away from here.”
...suggesting that he no longer wants to be
involved with the city, the crime that comes
with it, and of course, his job bringing those
criminals to justice.
Going back to his line on the bar, love costs,
love takes effort and work, but he just doesn’t
want to put that effort in anymore.
But by the time the fifth murder has taken place,
he’s decided to stay on to the end of the
case.
He has no real reason to do that other than
the fact that he cares about the outcome.
Then, at the end, even after John Doe gets
his way, by putting Mills’ wife’s head
in a box, causing Mills to retaliate and make
John the seventh and final victim… even
after all of that hurt and suffering, it sounds
like Somerset is still going to stay on.
"Where are you gonna be?"
"Around."
“Ernest Hemingway once wrote, ‘The world
is a fine place and worth fighting for.
I agree with the second part.’”
One of my favorite movie quotes of all time.
And Se7en also contains one of the better
movie villains of all time, but you probably
won’t see me doing an episode of Horror
History on John Doe, because the whole idea
behind his character is that he doesn’t
really have a history.
I already discussed the fact he’s basically
removed himself from the crimes he committed
by cutting the skin off of his fingers.
The name John Doe is also kind of ironic for
Somerset and Mills because John Doe is oftentimes
used as a placeholder name in the world of
law enforcement when a person’s name is
unknown or needs to be concealed.
There’s also the fact that for the first
half of the movie, we don’t see John Doe,
then when we do see him, he’s just a nondescript
guy in a trenchcoat -- great lengths are taken
to preserve his anonymity.
There is actually one exception to this.
After police discover the third victim, the
one representing Sloth, a supposed media photographer
comes to get some shots, but if we look very closely, it’s actually John Doe,
returning to the scene of the crime to document
what he had done, probably to add the images
to his notebooks on top of notebooks about
his work and the relation to the seven deadly
sins.
What he gets instead, is a very pissed off
Detective Mills, who swats at his camera and
chases him away.
This gives John Doe the opportunity to rile
him up, to test his restraint, which all plays
into his plan to make him commit the final
murder to represent Wrath.
This is the reason that he lets him live during
their next encounter, when Mills chases him
out of his apartment building into an alley,
where John Doe is able to catch him by surprise
and get the upper hand.
John’s objective is to use his crimes to
teach the world of their sins.
He had religious reasons behind what he did,
and he felt he had to do something big to
get the world’s attention.
However, he seemed to believe that he was
doing this entirely for the cause, and not
at all to bring attention to himself.
And that is what made him so difficult to
beat.
Despite being a criminal mastermind, he never
acted like he was anything more than just
another John Doe.
One of the images that comes up near the end
of Se-seven-en would bring the movie full
circle.
We started with subliminal messages being
spliced in, and in the penultimate scene,
an image of Mills’ wife, Tracy appears for
just 1 frame.
Director David Fincher would bring back the
idea of splicing single frames into movies
for his 1999 film, Fight Club, where one of
the characters in the movie literally does that.
"He had one part time job as a projectionist...
because it affords him other interesting opportunities."
"Like splicing single frames of pornography
into family films."
But Fight Club, and his previous work, the
1997 action film, The Game don’t really
fit in any way into the horror-thriller genre.
For that we have to skip ahead a few years
to 2002 for Panic Room, so lock your doors
and join me for the next episode of Things You Missed.
And make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we stay inside.